[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
what is going on there reject nation we
got coy with us today to watch the final
episode of miss marvel what where's jon
well i killed him nikoi has finally
replaced him
just like you all fears have come true
you manifested them you did this john is
out of commission he got the uh vid
diesel as i like to call it he's doing
fine he's boosted and vaxxed uh but and
we're pc hard and hydrated
we took multiple tests and we are fine
we are we tested negative so we're good
now we are here to watch the final
episode of miss marvel you know it's you
can do everything you've always wanted
which is a take over chest everyone's
like taking over the channel here's step
one step one eliminate john leave a like
that would be very much appreciated also
subscribe and click that notification
bell for something the koi's comic
corner we did that often we got a pretty
epic video coming epic one coming up for
uh ranking all the mcu films quite an
excellent job on that full-length
reaction watch alongs where you sync up
with the time coder over at our patreon
for super sexy rejects uh that's where
you sync up with your own copy i think
i'm said that everything right the boys
thank you
let's get to it wish john well in the
comments so we're gonna transfer the
next stop and head up state okay
it's okay wasn't easy one kamala first
got our powers either they're just like
that was weird
we live in new york in the marvel
universe
no jersey the passer buyers on that
subway station are just chilling
they're seeing some crazy another day in
the marvel cinematic universe his powers
are comic accurate to that and miss
marvel's now mirror his which is
interesting
i have an announcement drake all right
let's do forgiveness
i'm about to bear hero
i am
the light girl
nightlight
oh my god
i had no idea
oh my gosh
[Laughter]
are your powers limitless or do you have
to recharge oh actually also i have been
dying to ask you on eid did you drop
that kid on purpose or was that like a
game time decision
big bro
just because you you can do all these
amazing things
doesn't mean that you
actually volunteer to go looking for
trouble right
i don't think you raised me to sit by
and do nothing when i can help people i
miss the dad he's great yeah i love that
she has a family no one does yeah that's
true
and they're all like yeah we accept this
have you heard from bruno
no why i've been trying to get a hold of
him because
circle cue exploded
[Music]
kamala khan you're not going anywhere
not dressed like that
here
i got something for you
did she make her the costume that'd be
so cool no
that'd be the ultimate family yeah you
know
oh she's coming around oh
that's beautiful
sign of character i love that for this
family
[Music]
oh that's great i love that that's very
touching
[Music]
that's so touching
she's the first ipsu character that like
shares this yeah
openly yeah to this level like that's
beautiful
i'm a superhero
[Music]
that costume looks great
[Music]
oh that is so cool
[Music]
let's give it up for the vfx artist yeah
give it a please please
when the coast is clear you guys head to
the high school and i'll call kamala
why would we go to high school because
the only place guaranteed to be empty on
saturday
it's true she's smart
[Music]
this is an exciting episode
[Laughter]
costumes in the first 10 minutes
good afternoon i'm gonna need to see
everybody's
i
geez that was not our first rodeo miss
agent i assure you damage control is
only here to ensure your safety this is
not a racist thing at all white woman
this kid could put you all at risk if
you are abetting a potential suspect
no one will be on your side chic i don't
need anyone on my side for god is always
right i don't have time for chronic
quotes excuse me
actually that was abraham lincoln
racist dodc racist confirmed
[Music]
it's good that they didn't hide out at
that mosque
might have found them i know
my mom would kill me if she found that i
had a boyfriend and that it was
that one did you hear that i'm a
boyfriend
and you're both witnesses do you have a
body cam i'd love to have this one
[Laughter]
nice
yeah they were there take clifton street
whatever you do avoid grant thank you
why don't they see that door
sliding
[Music]
ah they all marvel disguise nice
[Music]
that's crazy these two are paired up
right now right and all brian
[Laughter]
[Music]
look at her go
[Music]
what are you guys wearing
[Laughter]
what are you wearing
awesomeness i was just scared i thought
i'm okay we're okay
tell her you love him
[Music]
i feel like i'm being crushed from the
inside out
yeah they're going to have heard that
it's nice to see a costume that's not
cgi at all yeah like
even the scarf
it's a scarf it's a real scarf
i really need to get him out of town
i know someone who can get him out
just get him to the harbor by midnight
okay
thank you
thor
captain marvish he knows he knows cat
marvel i tell you everything and this is
the biggest thing that's ever happened
to you and you didn't tell me so i mean
maybe okay but you like kind of hate
superheroes i didn't
want you to hate me
oh
when hate me hate me it's um
[Music]
i messed up i'm sorry
geez i love them such a good actor man
murder the dodc danish control is here
how do they even find us it doesn't
matter i'm the one they want you guys
should leave now before you get hurt i
already blew my apartment they invaded
the mosque
twice they tried to trick me into giving
you up
what are you doing here the theater has
good lighting
it's where i film my tick tocks
nice so we distract and stall for as
long as possible until we can get
cameron safe uh
yeah yeah excuse me hey uh are you sure
you have authorization for any of this
sounds good
we'll keep him busy while you run out
the back
mom send me a watch out for you um
take it up with her
i love this episode we grab every single
fire extinguisher in school
[Music]
very realistic you're on the softball
team right you and nokia grab as many
balls as you can
is this gonna be like home alone what's
going on guaranteed
i don't care if you need another 10
seconds okay
you're not gonna get it
evacuate now deever you hear me
[Music]
i understand
she's not gonna listen
we're in position do we have a green
light
[Music]
call in all additional units we have a
villain i think she's a skrull yeah
let's go there i hope so
[Laughter]
pretty hell bent on steamrolling over
our entire world with their realm okay
i just yeah to make it who are you even
doing my sister driving lessons
do you even like british break off
[Laughter]
do not tell carmen that
okay
not too well out of here
i think you should tell him now
make it high stakes that way he'll blow
all these people up it'll go well for
you oh
looks like we've got a bomb
[Music]
[Laughter]
the ultimate plan
[Music]
those clubbing cops they sent all of you
just for me
nice
okay so i'll play this live but i don't
know for a do do do that do now hey it's
so i'm at kohl's high school where
damage control is me and my friends
totally surrounded
hey say hang on help i'm coming
target on foot get a red hoodie and a
bait
[Music]
robinson i'm pat nicholson
this looks like a lot of fun
oh no
[Music]
chemistry
yes
your mom died i thought you should know
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god is this about to happen
hey you guys
i'm sorry bruno um there's a team
agent's heading down this way i'll keep
them busy
okay
come on come on
i'm rooting for you bruno that was that
hurts he already lost spiderman he can't
lose thanks bruno
[Music]
did you know that he was up for
spider-man was he yeah
i'm so glad he gave this because he's so
good in this
hey guys what's going on
oh god they are hurting him
[ __ ] wow
[Music]
wow there it is
[Music]
it's working
[Music]
they hate my mom i miss my mom i want to
talk to my mom call my mom what happened
to my mom
[Music]
oh now she's protecting him
my mother's dead
he's in chain
i'm sorry
[Music]
stop right there
oh my god he's gonna break bad
yep it's on now
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
i guess this leaves room for bruno
[Music]
i don't know why i'm getting like
terminator 2 vibes for some
[Music]
reason we go
[Music]
oh damn is that what they use on the
hulk i think so that big like yeah yeah
unless it's a laser
no
yeah
[Music]
wow this is so menacing
[Music]
who is this [ __ ] i think she's our
skrull
she said i'm biggen did she i think she
said i'm bigging
whoa
wild
[Laughter]
slight scorpion king vibes but you know
the vfx artist i'm so happy with it
[Laughter]
oh that's awesome
[Music]
the camera
[Music]
i love the variety and how he uses those
powers yeah there's like different
weapons
extend yeah it's like carnage
magic
hero moment
[Music]
oh yay she's a superhero
[Laughter]
[Music]
well that's not fun
[Music]
so trippy
yeah
[Music]
oh wow
it's like when strange in cases yeah
we're gonna have a conversation comrade
let's talk about this
get to the harbor
i'll buy you time get to the harbor
they both got like great grasps on their
powers now don't yeah
[Music]
she murdered that boy
she ate him
[Music]
that was amazing
they're all with you
oh
this is a spider-man yeah you're gonna
have to get through me
you went against my orders publicly and
then you attacked a bunch of kids using
our name and you know what that means
yes that means that you're relieved of
your duty a union is going to fix your
mess get out of there now
i would not want to get on his bad side
[Music]
oh she doesn't even get to celebrate
with the crowd she can go back
[Laughter]
today's news everyone keeps asking me
ruby ruby do you know who she is if i
knew who she was i wouldn't believe it
she looked so familiar
[Music]
that was the writer oh really yeah
oh that makes me happy what'd she say
when the jobs girls are the best in
jersey city
freaking action superhero math skills
but i don't know where those skills went
when she screamed pizza for life
celebrate our own superhero free ice
cream pizza after salah of course yeah
don't get addicted to social media the
trap don't do it it's not worth it
people are saying about my superpowers
online yeah woodrow wilson's the writer
and she was the one that said real gw
nice
[Music]
now cat marvel where are you
[Music]
i personally think this is a really
solid finale so far yeah this is
actually really solid
hey bro what are you doing here
whoa
oh my god
this is really scary
yeah right
yeah right
[Music]
well
you saved the world oh [ __ ]
that's what kamal means in arabic
perfect
but it will do it's more like
what's the word
wonder
marvel
i share the same name as freaking
danvers
[Laughter]
but you sure are
and always have been
our own little
miss marvel oh
gets the costume from the mom and the
name from the dad
that's beautiful i love that
i love you i love you
i cannot wait to see her interacting
with carol danvers in the movie like
tiana paris real estate and here
[Music]
magic
absolute magic
i will monetize my daughter
[Laughter]
there's the shot of the poster shot
[Music]
i like the costume a lot i love it yeah
it looks great
[Music]
oh
captain marvel's bunking with her heard
you like your name
when i compared you to the rest of your
family something still seemed off kamala
there's something different
in your genes
like
[Music]
like a mutation
this is the first real like
whatever it is it's just gonna be
another label
please please
oh dude i think your theory is going to
come true
dude
get in liz's we're getting schwarman i
love you
they're making her a mutant
i said this would leave yeah yeah you
did you gotta watch that one
[Music]
so
missed mutation mutation that's crazy
that's wild
right into a world that hates and fears
them through damage control that's just
gonna be another label oh dude do you
what
what video was that i don't even
remember i've been saying that video
there was a no you know it was a quiz
cover
corner i don't remember
i'll find it i was right
i don't remember the damn i was like
holy [ __ ] this is like exactly how yes
that's crazy that's how we got x-men
we're just trying to promote koi's comic
course yeah you should watch common
corner where i get right that was a
solid solid episode that was such a good
finale i enjoyed that a lot i think that
and loki are the best two finales it's
gotta be a post-credits scene right i
imagine what video was that
no memory of which one it was was it the
thunderbolts video yes yes apartment
damage control and all that yeah so do
you think comrade would be in the dodc
no not the dude sorry though
thunderbolts
comrade probably not but i think he'll
be one of the mutants that
is a villain like an early brotherhood
of evil mutants kind of thing yeah yeah
like you know setting up dates and fears
them like everyone shut up
oh my god
[Laughter]
[Music]
called it how did she contact her
no she is hurt the band had pulled her
out and put her in oh [ __ ] she's gone
[Music]
that costume is great too the new one
oh yeah
that's the most excited i've been to see
captain marvel
i was like
cool
that was spectacular i've just been
saying since last episode you know i
kept saying that we gotta get that
captain marvel cameo and so and the new
suit i'm so happy to just get my captain
marvel there it is there's the magic
that's what we'll put in the thumbnail
people will love it people will be so
happy i'll be so like i wasn't gonna
watch this but now i don't think you
spoiled it i think you encouraged me to
watch it that's what they'll say yeah
yeah they'll say that exactly all right
man well we got we got chit chat there's
some stuff to say you want to play back
that q real quick
the what the music queue make sure i'm
not crazy
yeah
yes okay i'm not crazy all right well we
just played back the audio of it and koi
pointed the shot
in between because you're doing the tick
tock really quick and you said that the
the
music yeah and i i didn't hear it i
think i was just so excited to hear the
word mutation that that literally
like the like the x-men animated series
it's so fun i love how much uh marvel
studios honors the x-men animated series
you know like you hear that tune in
doctor strange multiverse of madness for
a little bit now you hear it here is the
indication of the mutants they're
bringing back x-men 97. yeah i don't
think it's a coincidence expert 97. well
it's going to be michael yeah
uh i think expert 97 and what if we're
going to be interesting bedfellows
because i do think expert 97 is going to
be canon and it ties into the original
x-men 90s animated series guys we have
mutants in the mcu and we've been having
a hang with one for six episodes yeah i
know that's kind of crazy like this
whole time we've had a mutant here so
they didn't do terrigen mist but they
did mutants which is more linear to be
honest like i i like the inhumans but i
love the mutants i like the inhuman
storyline and i like the inhumans versus
the mutants but it is at the end of the
day a way more streamlined version to
have a character we're invested in be a
mutant and i love that she's like just
another label i like that they are
already like nipping that in the bud and
addressing the world that hates and
fears them from the jump and yeah and
this was the first show i mean you know
falcon winter soldier dealt with
variations of racism obviously but this
one really is a culture as a people
really dealt with racism a lot and so
you know when knowing that what x-men
mutants allegories are so much for that
like oh you're planting the seeds for
that what better show than a show that
deals with you know surveillance in a
mosque and people judging you
immediately and like you know a fairly
racist government government wanting to
shut you down and what you are and i've
been saying it for months and kids
shouldn't have powers right stuff so
yeah like it's a threat to be born with
that also it activates puberty yes yeah
this is she's the youngest of the
experts she's the youngest of the marvel
characters dude that's right oh snaps
and this is all coming in post snap so
this is not something that is i want to
talk about the actual episode but it is
obviously the big thing yeah so this is
something that won't be you know a
combination of of like mutants from
another universe smashing here and it is
that we are starting mutation here in
the mcu yeah and she's you know the
first character to be in reverence of
the characters we've had so far so i'm
wondering if it's something about the
planet and like things that have been
happening that caused mutation to occur
like i'm wondering if it's gonna be a
ramification of the events of blank
because we're you know we're
chronologically deep into the mcu the
mcu itself is 14 years old in our
continuity but also in universe she's
old enough to worship these characters
because they've done their deeds yeah so
i'm wondering if that's gonna be a thing
where you know you have characters that
worship uh and then you find out like oh
the reason mutation exists is some [ __ ]
wow
it's kind of this is pretty cool so cool
it's funny that they they wrote this
show off so like a lot of people haven't
been to
the show and they bring the x-men which
is the number one interview yeah yeah
they bring the mutants in i'm like oh
damn the ending of this is a pretty big
setup it's the most important thing for
a lot of people and this show was
extremely important and now they got to
watch it and also you know i i do think
that not many post credit scenes for
these shows lead obviously we were it
was
it was safe to presume that captain
marvel would show up as a way to tease
what's going on what's going on in that
post-credit scene uh i think that the
bangle brought her into space maybe it
matched its pair
fascinating i think decree lost an arm
and another cree had the bangle and she
just got booted right into a crease girl
war oh damn i think she got [ __ ] up
she got booted through a beverage
[ __ ] preschool
captain
brother i was at a pre-school world now
i'm in a bedroom what gifts i see me all
over the walls i don't want to see
what's going on tiana paris maybe she's
photon maybe she's spectrum maybe she's
captain marvel now we're the marvels and
then we got secret innovation too not
sure what accent though uh secret
invasion i think is gonna be with the
marvel's
[Laughter]
we just wrote it you're welcome uh i
think that uh melissa mccarthy is
captain mark she is she's all three of
them yeah like teddy murphy yeah i'm
three women in shots
uh i think that the events of captain
marvel 2 are going to directly lead into
secret invasion but i also think that
like this is going to be a movie already
in progress when we go that post credit
scene is i think a mid action set piece
and i also loved her new suit oh yeah
yeah that'd be cool would this be the
first
show to feature a scene from a movie
anyway i think the scene like remember
when civil war when we saw bucky in his
arm in the thing yeah then we saw that
scene i think that scene we just saw is
going to be from the other side of the
movie awesome i think we're going to see
brie larson get bloop and you know yeah
yeah that's going to be dope or it just
starts moments
either way yeah it's either directly in
or we see you know what i mean
the audience is going to be there like i
didn't watch miss marvel
that's on you it's on you you should
have watched it this is a weird
we got a spectrum we got ourselves a
marble we got a little mine we got a
miss we got a captain k-pop
keep up with us i was so impressed with
this episode we should talk about the
episode um no mutants
i do not envy anyone that didn't stay up
till midnight tonight because it's gonna
be trending all night like that you
cannot avoid that tomorrow that's a
that's a hell of a twist it's like it
suddenly makes a lot of things click
that's what you want from like this kind
of landing right if you want a moment to
be like well of course and yet you also
uh we didn't see it well i mean i
i'm gonna claim some credit i did say
this was coming i just didn't know it'd
be like with a music cue like i said
this was gonna be the show that led to
x-men i've been saying that for the last
few months i didn't know it was gonna be
like
mutation that's crazy yeah that's right
that's fantastic you thought you think
like oh in the next installment or
whenever it comes around then they'd
show it but i didn't think the show
itself would set the groundwork forward
and like in in a way that really cues
the audience in yeah i didn't think we'd
hear the word yeah i know it's the first
time we've heard mutation other than
like you know
that'll let there be carnage i mean
cinema
i uh i do also think that there's an
interesting aspect of like told you so
with kevin feige being like this
marvel's really important i really like
that
saying that oh yeah yeah i also think
that this is the last show before comic
con so
now we got gods and time travel and but
think about it like if you're going to
announce it all age and you're going to
have a saturday crazy man now this is
the one that's 10 days before like i
said it's coming
i like i and like they don't do anything
half way they don't schedule things like
a lot of times these things lead next to
the other the announcement of this show
with the panel like marvel doesn't need
to go to comic-con they have d23 you got
a couple of weeks now yeah right this is
because of comic-con that like i mean
the comic-con i think is because of the
show not the other way around yeah
i think that this episode really stuck
the landing yes you know a lot of the
times with these disney plus shows
you end up walking away feeling like
because it actually i thought earned
when it got big haha big and i think it
earned when it got big with the action
uh
and i know that people have their
feelings about the one division finale
and 10 10 10 10 people have their
feelings about the one division finale
oftentimes we're left feeling like
that's pretty rushed they kind of tried
packing it you needed more episodes
that's usually more episodes three women
italians
very challenged
it's two in the morning
wearing chocolate
guys you're annoying
we're talking about
like some beautiful films he's always
got great like film perspective and he'd
be interrupting our like garish melissa
mccarthy okay
we bring the important colors here
there's a beautiful shot in this where
the camera actually goes under a truck
and then it like lifts and moves in a
way that i'm not sure how they shot it
now what would comrade you're talking
about right where it goes
with his foot like and then she comes
almost like handheld like it starts off
as a thing that looks like it's on a
crane and it's actually like a guy's
holding it yeah it's i wonder if they
did like a hidden swipe there or
something like that so impressed like it
looks like an old david fincher shot
that would be cgi where would like go
through glass but instead it couldn't be
yeah because someone's wheeled kid on
the other side that's such a dope shot i
view i'm constantly looking at visual
effects now with marvel with a certain
eye
to go do they have enough time to finish
this doesn't matter i think they did a
great job you know like there are times
where it looks a little cheesy i think
anything stretch even though this is not
full on like mr fantastic stretch
related that's still
some of the hardest technology i think
you've got to pull off
anything with expansion of limbs or
anything like that even if you're just
kenny valley-tastic it's literally like
straight you're making a body amorphous
yeah yeah and i think the the the
sequences with her when she is in
beginning i enjoyed them overall i think
no matter what even if sometimes effects
look a tad bit off i think that this
episode was all about the catharsis and
the emotion behind it more than anything
else like you get such a great wrap up i
i love the wrap up here because you had
like a show in the beginning that was
like a teen show right like a teen high
school show and then next thing you know
like you're in the middle east for a few
episodes yeah and then when you come
back to jersey
they bring it all together really well
and in a very rewarding way ultimately
like i thought the emotion behind it was
so
joyous a lot of the time and touching
like the fact that her family
was the thing that gave her because i i
was always curious like how are they
going to tie this in with the pakistani
culture or even more make it full circle
and then they did it with even with the
family being the ones who give her the
suit and give her the title as well
which
we talked about from like how it was in
the first episode where they're like
kind of oppressive towards her ambitions
and this whole fantasy
suits exactly she wasn't allowed to wear
superhero costumes they made her one and
yeah then they make her one it's like
this feeling of uh acceptance and she's
been more accepting of uh her roots as
well and then her name being uh a root
to her family and then that being the
root of miss marvel is that in the comic
that kamala means um marvel is that like
uh i mean i feel like if it really means
that then it just really just changed
that like yeah in this universe
uh i don't remember it being mentioned
and now i feel like a bad fan but i
don't remember that because that moment
felt really new and special to me yes
i'm sure it is but it might have been
like issue one that was
yeah i mean eight or nine years ago uh
for me reading it but i do think that it
was really smart to make it about her
ancestry in a different way like it's
beautiful that it's a translation of her
own name and like that moment of glee
where she shares with carol danvers and
then it's her name like all of that is
about heritage all that is about
ancestry about culture this show thrived
on family ancestry culture action hearts
and then the movie
the show landed with this great you know
heist uh home yes like you know all of
that really worked the action worked for
me there was a couple times brother
coming around too dude
the moment the kid rode the bike by on
the fire extinguisher i was like i wish
i had seen the show in high school this
would be my favorite show i think that
this this finale brought the two kinds
of shows together that they were doing
impossibly like how did the show balance
those tones yeah it's like some stuff i
mean i don't even know like there's
nothing i'm sure if i slowed down and
was like what what can i critique i got
no notes man uh i i'm sure there's stuff
uh but to me it was just about the
experience of this episode and i thought
this was a wonderful experience overall
i think loki is the most consistent um
in one tone and i think one division is
the most impressively bold as far as
what it tried to accomplish at the top
this is probably the most impressive
balance of tones like it does the most
different stuff and that's saying
something because one division is
literally a show that is sitcom tropes
to open the show like this show's
insanely accomplished and i loved when
like everyone gathered around to protect
her at the end so to stand by yes to
stand by wither and you've said several
times that miss marvel in a lot of ways
is like uh what would you say
spider-man so that's what he says
silverade spider-man has a lot of this
really cool he protects his town
personally he's got a lot of family
elements his friends me a lot he's
always the underdog chasing balancing
school and work and being spider-man all
of that to me is what makes spider-man
so approachable everyone can understand
like i can't do all of these things at
once and i've got this stress
spider-man's us
to me what i love about kamala khan is
those silver age spider-man tropes made
sense to me because i identified with
all of those things including being like
a straight white dude kamala khan made
all those things make sense to me and
i've never been
a girl a person of color um
i'm not religious at all so i've never
had any religious uh persecution or or
judgments so it was really interesting
to read those comics and be like oh i
get 90 of this world but the extra 10
means so much for me because i don't
understand any of this context but i
still identify yeah and that's so
special and so hard to accomplish then
this [ __ ] show did it yeah
and they to my understanding they honor
the comics pretty well it felt like the
comics how so in the end even zoe being
a good girl again yeah so he teams up i
do like that that that at the very end
of this that the powers do come from her
with within her yeah ultimately
um because i mean even though the show
already established that prior very
shang chi like which had the ten rings
thing too in here there's rings out
there
when they tell you how phase four all
connects i can't wait dude i think the
rings uh that
chongqi wares are made by fastos and i
think the bangle she wears is made by
fastos and i think that all of them
haven't established that yet but they're
about to they're about to they're about
to go
first they're kevin feige he's going to
get he's going to be like yo
fast brian's tyrion comes out and he's
just making stuff and then i then i come
out on stage and it's dinner and i'm
like also expert oh [ __ ] that would be
cool see you at comic-con on stage uh i
didn't catch who directed this one the
original the the homies the fans of the
show the two uh that's the brothers yeah
or their brothers they're just best
friends the reject nation fans yeah uh
you get their style here it's pretty
prevalent i thought they did a really
good job with the action
and i think that they also provided
moments that were more menacing than
previous episodes like there was some
real
dramatic heft within the action scenes
at times like especially when comrad is
going through all these internal moments
of
which which path do i go down and
dealing with the feelings of his mom
knowing that she's dead
i really liked those action scenes a lot
where they the film would go into slow
motion mode and then you'd see kamala
like trying to process this they had a
lot of good visual body language
just between just in the action scenes
as you're watching these motives either
increase you know especially when it
comes to kamala who moments before was
about to you know kiss komron and then
now here
when she's making the decision to like
like i like how a lot of it just wasn't
spoken for example when the dodc guy's
in the bathroom and he's about to attack
uh she he's about to attack him and she
decides to protect him like you could
feel this
yeah this gap happening between them and
the way they shot him in those scenes
where it got extreme close up and the
sweat and the agony and the suffering
like there was a lot that was actually
the first time their style reminded me
of what they did in bad boys in a very
positive way mixed with their style
choices here yes i was thinking uh yeah
this stylistically is i i like their
work so much and i gotta include they're
gonna include better music this time
around badass rap music there was so
much cool stuff in this tonally and it
built out a world that feels really
special like i i said when chongqing
ended this is the thing i want a sequel
to most in the mcu
miss marvel's second like i think of
anything we've seen post endgame this is
the world i want to dive deeper into
along with chungchi yeah and you guys
know i love eternals you yell at me all
the time but like this is what i want to
see i want to invest more in kamala
khan's world and i can't wait for not
only does miss marvel 2 give or captain
marvel to the marvels give me hope for
captain marvel because i love the
character of captain marvel in the comic
books most of the time i love brie
larson most the time captain marvel the
movie didn't work for me but nia de
costa who directed candyman with tiona
paris whose spectrum in captain marvel
in juan division that duo was so
incredible and the visuals need acosta
used in handyman all of those things
give me so much hope already for the
marvels and then this show just put the
marvels like you combine what i am
hopeful for with the director of the new
duo and this show ending and how this
landed like i think the marvels is
maybe in my top three most anticipated
marvel properties going forward now
i really liked the delivery that brie
larson did in that one little one yeah i
was like
i don't know i was like
i like free larsen i wasn't a big fan of
her performance in captain marvel and i
usually think pretty large is a pretty
damn good actress yeah so
i don't know there's something about
that moment that just felt very natural
to me yeah it wasn't something i was
really saying
no no we both had a moment of like this
is nice yeah yeah i liked it i liked it
i i like this version and i like the
costume i like that it feels more like i
wonder who directed that scene wonderful
it might be nina costa well i thought
that the um
i think that this episode overall was
just a great it really hit the landing
the family stuff with the emotional
beast
i'm so sorry huh no it's okay because we
love john
it's usually like ah you did someone
talks i'm usually i'm usually conducting
of like yeah you took now you talk now i
talk or something like but when you're
conducting you're telling yourself the
time to talk so instead i'm like but i
have things to say like i'm just
okay i just want to apologize but uh you
were saying about freelancers can you
catch yourself with that because then
someone might say that here in the
comments but just so you know i'm like i
don't care
bring coy here to talk
i like least talking i have to do the
better off i am around he's already done
it
i'm done three girls in charge checked
out man i uh i feel like the family
stuff to open the episode was genius and
then that
re-established what the tone of the
first half of the show was right and
then by the time you got to where the
moments ago events had happened you're
like oh right that's what this show is
and then it gave us all new stuff like
this is a master class in
finale it wraps up so many story lines
it introduces new ideas it gives you
action drama heart it gives you all the
characters you've loved reminds you of
something you'd forgotten about and then
it launches the next thing like this
every issue i've had with phase four has
been when creative freedom sacrifices
the integrity of characters this is how
you do it this show is stylistically
[ __ ] dope this show introduces new
characters this show gives you a brand
new world to invest in the characters
you just met and makes you love them and
it doesn't sacrifice the mcu while still
building it out this is what i want out
of these movies
i was going to say several things along
those lines okay
um
yeah uh they did family stuff and uh
powers and mutation was and they set up
things right that's what you said right
yeah you had a good checklist here i did
i said those words in a similar order i
think that they what because in the
first episodes that's when they were
doing very stylistic with it's like
scott pilgrim influences right
and then here i felt like they really
found kind of a more unique
look that wasn't just
clearly inspired by scott pilgrim yeah
and i think it at times did kind of
remind me of a comic panel i thought the
colors really popped well like i noticed
when comrade walked out into where all
the cops are
everything was blue and that's his power
that's his power looking like it's like
this is his power position right now
everything's blue before he's even
attacked anyone his clothes are blue his
powers are blue the lighting's blue
everything around him is blue until it
they i think they use a lot of great
illumination with the power sets yeah
and i thought the powers actually looked
pretty neat in this one i know that
people sometimes the visual effects can
be a little bit wonky but i really do
this whole talk about visual effects
ours has just made me go i want to
appreciate what they do more because
especially in such a crunch time because
marvel's like
we'd have none of the well every studios
like we'd have none of this without
them
it's like mainly warner brothers yeah
let's attack them while we're in the
moment you know what i feel like that's
what we're talking about i was trying to
think of a studio that's like defunct
and i couldn't really like be sure you
know
man yeah you know 8 24 with their garage
struggling
having a hard time columbia house
[Music]
yeah we did what was the one that
produced terminator corona oh no
we should wrap this video
cannon with a cannon c-a-n-o-n iconic
colors it was like yeah
where you can go
down to coco all right guys what did you
think about this finale
um we got to get coy to theorize about
some [ __ ] you guys want to see another
comic corner that's been birthed from
this moment that would be amazing but
look before we wrap this up let's do it
let me do one they don't even patronize
me i just love them oh i heard about
eric horseman what a nice guy we talked
about him last time you pick a name
craig do that thing with you
and let me know what it's doing
gabriel shout out gabriel gabriel you
are lovely i like your double use of hay
you are the sponsor of the day i
appreciate your zeal i appreciate your
name and i appreciate the fact that you
may or may not be named after an angel
of vengeance it's good it's a good thing
to be named that is a great thing to be
named after it's like you're doing
vengeance for us by being at our patreon
page by supporting us your protector i
assume they go by gabe but i wonder if
they ever go by brielle i think it's gab
gab gab i've never been a brielle but
it's a kind of a cool name it sounds
like literary like real have you ever
met a gab they want to kill themselves
thank you it hasn't gone well for them
i've met some games
never a brielle or a gab though
why do we shorten names so weird why is
why is robert bob
his last name
i don't know if i could say his last
name do you want it like legally or
pronounce it i don't know
i think it's french
i don't want to be it's not like we're
reading his email out it sounds like the
what's the song that goes i'll be
bulletproof who's that artist
that wasn't a lot of rap that didn't
sound like a rap to me no i'll be
bullied
proof is that like a edm thing
yeah yeah that does look like that is
that the thing you're singing that's you
you're bulletproof you're trying to tie
it back into him you're bored i don't
know gabriel like an angel of vengeance
is bulletproof koi's never kicked off a
shout out and this is where it's gone
poorly all right bye everyone
thanks gabriel
[Music]